thank you rocky we appreciate it the mob
museum is celebrating its 10th
anniversary on february 14th and here
tell us about more about this major
milestone is stephen lackey the senior
director of development it's good to see
you good to see you as well we are
extremely excited about this 10th year
anniversary you know valentine's day is
a day of love and giving and so we're
going to show some love to the city that
kind of made us great you're giving back
to las vegas absolutely on the 14th it's
our one of our annual free days so
nevada residents get entry into the
museum for free
we're going to have 10 percent off all
food and beverage for folks there we've
got a wonderful car show which is really
okay go on we've got some old school
cars i mean we've got a model t club
there so from about 10 o'clock until the
close of the business we've got a ton of
cars there's just a ton of fun stuff
going on with 14 for you guys now you
guys opened up uh 10 years ago february
14th is a reason why you guys opened up
on valentine's day valentine's day
massacre wow that's the connection right
there there's a connection and within
the museum we've actually got a part of
the wall from
yeah the museum has some innovative very
interesting historical artifacts that
connect to organized crime but also the
story of law enforcement responds to
organized crime and it's very
interactive too he brought a couple
things here and i do have to hold one of
these items up because this is very
special what am i what am i holding
right you're holding an award-winning
moonshot this is real moonshine this is
real moonshine directly from our
distillery at the museum and it is the
real deal and people can come down the
museum they can drink this you're
welcome to come down and drink some we
have a tank
you're welcome to overnight okay he is
opening the first tenth and first round
right now no no you are
this is the inaugural
shot well this is the real deal
okay look
you take a swig of it take a stiff a
sniff or swing you decide i drink a
moonshine on tv
whoa
that's good stuff this could that car
show you have coming up this kid this
can actually get the cars moving it's
wonderful stuff i mean we've won several
awards for we've got several different
flavors of moonshine but really that
speakeasy that we have downstairs
that's one of the things we offer to the
community
people tell me that they're going to the
museum i tell them they need two days
there's so much to see down there is so
much to see and you have a special gala
that's coming up so the 14th we're all
going to celebrate you guys what's
happening is it on the second absolutely
on the 17th we've got our first ever
gala and we're not doing your typical
you know go to a big building and hang
out we're doing a gala over the four
floors of the museum we're gonna have i
mean food stations live music um our
co-chairs mayor carolyn and oscar of
course yes we'll be there we're also
going to be honoring a number of law
enforcement individuals a bunch of
undercover agents so the gala is called
undercover of the night and we're going
to be honoring one of the individuals
who was credited with bringing down over
200 mobsters wow so we can't say his
name
is he's still working under are we going
to blow his cover he's undercover
tonight so he may or may not be there
but we will be honoring him at a number
of law enforcement well okay
so we're going to say the
congratulations to tom smith who's been
better today and he we're not going to
point him out we're just going to know
that he might be undercover
that's undercover of the night we love
everything you've given back to this
city or such a crucial part of las vegas
10 years is a huge milestone what can we
expect over the next 10 years from the
museum you know the museum is looking to
expand our footprint we have just been
an amazing part of the downtown's
resurgence and so we are an anchor
organization we are you know humanities
organization we are a museum but we
really are a business model for all of
downtown absolutely done great work so
we're excited about the work we're
looking forward to 10 more years um just
just over the moon about i love it
here's to 10 more years of the mob
museum we're gonna drink some moonshine
the big celebration is happening on
monday valentine's day the 14th of
february jillian send it over to you
take a sip take us out take a sip take a
sip come on
you gotta get in on the celebrations
how was it smile
my hair's gonna stand up